jon snow house of the dragon the sea
snake let's review every game of thrones
spin-off currently in development as
well as every rumored series still on
the horizon
there are currently seven game of
thrones spin-offs in development that we
know about while the final season of
game of thrones may have left a sour
taste in many viewers mouths the
excitement for shows like house of the
dragon and the now confirmed jon snow
sequel series is at an all-time high
today we're going to be breaking down
everything we know about the 7 spin-offs
in development and stick around to the
end to find out how one spin-off was
quickly cancelled costing hbo over 30
million dollars
[Music]
the first game of thrones spin-off on
our list and the one i'm most excited
about is the untitled jon snow sequel
series with the working title snow kit
harrington is set to reprise his role as
jon snow after his exile in game of
thrones when he went to live with the
wildlings north of the wall along with
his friend tormund giant spain it's
still uncertain whether the show will
follow jon and his adventures north of
the wall or if he'll be pulled back into
the politics of the south seeing as how
he's now living with the wildlings we
may even get to see flashbacks to jon's
time with his first love interest egret
played by kitt harrington's real-life
wife rose leslie since jon snow's story
was one of the most exciting out of any
character from game of thrones this show
is sure to be one of the most highly
anticipated spin-offs in this list we
still don't know much about the show or
whether it will ever make it out of the
development stage but we can be sure
that its potential for success certainly
depends on the success of the next
spin-off in our list house of the dragon
based on george rr martin's book fire
and blood house of the dragon picks up
the story 200 years before game of
thrones the first season of the show is
currently being released and a second
season has already been confirmed the
show follows the war of succession
within the house targaryen called the
dance of dragons house of the dragon
will have 10 episodes in the first
season and it's been so popular that
when the pilot was released it actually
caused hbo max's servers to crash it'll
be exciting to see where this series
takes us and how it may cross over with
the next spin-off on our list the sea
snake one of the most striking
characters from the house of the dragon
was the master of ships on the king's
council lord corliss velaryon played by
steve tucson also known as the sea snake
corliss earned his reputation through
his infamous adventures as a naval
warrior which this series is likely to
follow the sea snake is currently being
written by the mentalist creator bruno
heller prior to pitching the sea snake
heller also approached hbo about a
prequel series focused on robert
baratheon and ned stark's rebellion
against the mad king which immediately
precedes game of thrones so there could
be one more spin-off in the works
somewhere surrounding the story of
robert's rebellion quick plug if you
like what you're seeing hit that
subscribe button to see more videos like
this now on to the next series in our
list another spin-off in development
following some adventurers in westerosi
waters is titled ten thousand ships set
a thousand years before game of thrones
the series is set to focus on a key
figure within westerosi legend princess
nymeria the founder of dorne nymeri was
mentioned both in house of the dragon
and game of thrones in which arya stark
chose the name nymeria for her direwolf
her journey will take her to many
different lands around the summer sea
from the dinosaur-infested jungles of
cethorios to the tropical paradise of
the summer islands before she finally
migrates to dorne where she'll set the
roots for the ancestors of the modern
dornishmen and house martel ten thousand
ships is one of the show's furthest
along in its development and the sea
snake's title was even changed from its
original name the nine voyages to avoid
too many titles with numbers in them
person of interest writer amanda segel
has been attached to 10 000 ships and
george rr martin has said that the
project is progressing quite well the
next spin-off series will feature the
iconic knight sir duncan the tall or
dunk and esquire egg who is destined to
become king aegon targaryen v this
series has a couple of rumored names
including dunkin egg and a knight of the
seven kingdoms the series will likely
have three seasons closely adapting the
stories from george rr martin's novellas
the hedge knight the sworn sword and the
mystery knight all of which take place
approximately 90 years before game of
thrones helmed by steve conrad this
series is expected to be a very faithful
adaptation of martin's stories which is
exactly what martin wants according to
his personal blog the next series in our
list is actually an animated series with
the working title the golden empire and
it's set to take place in yiti a country
in essos loosely based on imperial china
martin has only said that a young writer
is working on the show but that the
early artwork is stunning it's likely
the story will follow the collapse of
the great empire of the dawn and it may
surround the civil war between the
transition of power between two great
dynasties early on in the history of ut
next up on our list of spin-offs is a
prequel to game of thrones set and flea
bottom the slums of king's landing this
area is notorious for its high level of
crime and it's where the poorest
residents of the westeros capital live
it's in these areas where characters
such as sir davos seaworth and gendry
baratheon were raised and it's likely
that if this series makes it out of
development that the story will follow
one of these characters or another we've
seen before in game of thrones now that
we know every game of thrones spin-off
currently in development let's talk
about how hbo mistakenly lost over 30
million dollars on one episode of a
spin-off that's never seen the light of
day
the series was titled blood moon and it
took place during the long night around
8 000 years before the time of game of
thrones this wasn't an easy project to
develop especially since martin had only
written a few sentences about the time
period across all of his books martin
himself admitted blood moon was a very
difficult assignment we're dealing with
a much more primitive people there were
no dragons yet however showrunner jane
goldman pushed on to create a 30 million
dollar pilot episode one of the most
expensive pilots ever made the episode
featured naomi watts as well as several
other talented cast members and it
surrounded a wedding between a great
northern house and a southern house but
hbl pulled the plug on the project in
late 2019. robert greenblatt the former
chairman of hbo's parent company warner
media said about the show it wasn't
unwatchable or horrible or anything it
was very well produced and looked
extraordinary but it didn't take me to
the same place as the original series it
didn't have that depth and richness that
the original series pilot did the
strangest thing about it all though
george rr martin still hasn't seen the
pilot episode it was locked away likely
alongside the original unaired pilot for
game of thrones which was almost
entirely re-shot and recast if martin
hasn't seen blood moon's pilot and hbo
execs weren't willing to do reshoots for
the episode i think it's pretty likely
the show was well beyond saving but what
do you think about this 30 million
dollar blunder drop your thoughts in the
comment section below also check out the
video on your screen for some more of my
content don't forget to like and
subscribe and thanks for watching rocket
riley